it's been a wild week here in Rio de
Janeiro Brazil where we definitely are
with our comedians fighting tooth and
nail for a spot in tonight's final at
the non trademark infringing
coincidentally Olympic style tournament
please don't sue us already this week
we've eliminated a Russian learned how
much Canadians sweat and suspended a
competitor for doping it's very dramatic
very dramatic week now we're left with
three of the world's greatest comedians
going head-to-head to see who will bring
home the gold and who will just bring
home Zika they're gonna take it home and
spread it gonna be the zombie apocalypse
figure out which loved ones you'd have
to take out when they get it first then
look around and figure out who you'd
have to repopulate with once a zombie
apocalypse starts don't worry the zombie
apocalypse will prevent a trump
presidency
let's meet our finalists first up
representing Great Britain the nation
that brought us movies you go see with
your mom and charming ways to say the
word it's Gina yeah sure
next up representing Germany our proud
nation but not too proud because they
know it makes you nervous
and finally representing news Becca Stan
a nation probably known for its hats and
let's just say autumn goat festivals
probably mulana by true
comedians now that you didn't reach a
bring gear nation eternal glory how will
your home country celebrate your victory
Jeana
well obviously I'm from Great Britain
and we give back so when I win we will
be giving out free English lessons to
all Americans listen we bastardize the
language it's herb it's bad all right
Flula Borg oh sorry Chris actually we
are still not allowed to celebrate
anything
a lot of fine true we'll celebrate the
same way we do everything Chris with no
media coverage